welcome back to Facebook I'm joined by
my Super PAC the talk to me contributor
Esther crackers associate author Grace
Blakely and from New York The Spectators
associate editor Douglas Murray welcome
to all of you I want to start uh with
you Douglas Kevin Spacey a dramatic turn
of events today where Kevin Spacey was
found not guilty of all charges in the
sex assault case this despite being
already convicted by the inevitable
Court of public opinion on social media
for a year this is what he said when he
came out of court afterwards
I would like to say
that I'm enormously grateful to the jury
for having taken the time
to examine all of the evidence and all
of the facts
carefully
before they reach their decision
and I am humbled
by the outcome today
and what was interesting uh I thought
Douglas was
um the number of people I've heard on
the Airways commentators broadcasters
and so on saying You know despite this
it's going to be almost impossible for
Kevin Spacey to get his career back in
Hollywood to which my response
instinctively is why the guy's just been
found not guilty right have we got this
to me is the is the personification of
cancel culture where someone is found
innocent on all charges and yet there's
a kind of presumption that he can't
return to his previous career
well one thing appears is I mean you
said that this is a surprising verdict
it's not surprising at all Kevin
Spacey's been exonerated at each of the
trials he's been put through he's
exonerated in the U.S last year he was
exonerated today in London anyone who
followed the U.S trial of civil case of
Anthony rat knows that Anthony Rapp made
false allegations against Kevin Spacey
that were proved to be false in the U.S
court now if anyone followed closely the
incredibly weak appalling uh case that
the CPS brought against him in the UK
the the four um claimants had one of the
weakest cases I have ever seen brought
before a jury and nobody who followed
this case could possibly be surprised
that the jury came back saying that
Kevin Spacey was innocent he has been
repeatedly proven innocent in court for
six years now he has been put through
the most incredibly intense
um cancellation you could possibly
imagine six years of false allegations
against him and a destroyed career and
just remember before this he was one of
the most successful actors on the planet
the House of Cards was the most
successful Show on Netflix this shows
what happens when a society loses grip
of the idea of innocent until proven
guilty and decides always believe the
alleged Victim Because you know what
sometimes the alleged victim is a an
absolute provable liar and that has been
the case in the trials of Kevin Spacey
and I wish that our society would learn
something from it it's yeah listen Grace
it's a it's you know I look at Kevin
Spacey I see a guy life ruined he's got
no money left apparently who came out in
court he's got no career no one will
hire him everyone dropped him like a
sack of Spuds social media persecutes
him mercilessly convicts him and so on
what does it say about our society this
this guy turns out to have been innocent
of all charges but is dead and buried in
terms of his career I don't know if it
says something about our society you
know these cases are complicated they're
always incredibly complicated because
they often boil down to he said he said
she said obviously it is incredibly
important to maintain this idea of
innocent and proven guilty until proven
guilty social media
discussed behind the scenes what you
know if people say he's not going to
work again what you know there's always
this idea of there are people who it's
an Open Secret that they do actually
yeah
talk about specifically about the court
of public opinion fueled on social media
which is so merciless that it makes
people so damaged because I do peers
that that is what happens when you put
yourself into public eye you know there
is there are going to be people who are
going to want to take you down and you
know we have a legal system for this
reason it's to try and get to the truth
at the bottom of some of these
allegations to make sure that people are
um the these things legally at least do
abide by the principle of innocent until
proven guilty there's nothing you can do
short of literally censoring free speech
to stop public figures from being
attacked well actually what you can do
Esther I mean I saw that on the Hugh
Edwards story for example when a lot of
other BBC male presenters started being
inaccurately accused of being that
person you know Jeremy Vine was one of
the people who took legal action against
one of these people and actually did
make the person pay a thousand pounds to
a charity maybe public figures just do
need to start suing people on social
media on a regular basis to make them
realize you can't just say everything
you want and you feel like it when
someone's facing a trial that could be
the end of their entire careers well
that's certainly part of it but I think
two things need to be done here one if
if a claim meant in a case like this is
has proven proven to be a liar they need
to be prosecuted we really need to
tighten the laws on these things because
these acutely affects
if you say if it's proven because it's
difficult because then you don't want to
disincentivate thank you
social media companies do not abide by
the same regulations that say the print
media do or broadcast media do and it's
a massive
problems
I think it's insane they are Publishers
and they should be triggered
I need to make a point about this
because actually this isn't just about
social media it's also about the media
the media went huge internationally when
Anthony Rapp made his initial provably
false allegation about Kevin Spacey the
international media around the world
went huge on that allegation it was only
an allegation now of course social media
then whipped it along and made it even
worse and made his career even more in
tatters but if you look at the fact how
many viewers know that that Kevin Spacey
was exonerated last year in the U.S
courts on the Anthony rap charges though
this is a fault of the media as well the
media very often whip along the initial
claims and do not cover the subsequent
judicial findings and that is a major
problem of the media not just of social
yeah I think that's actually it's legit
because a lot of the media doesn't cover
things that they consider to be boring
yeah and that's like a matter
I mean we can blame the media but I
think the bigger the bigger conversation
is culture right just for every person
that is saying that Kevin Spacey was
guilty there needs to be 10 people
saying wait until he has been proven
guilty we don't see that on social media
and the reason for it is because we are
so averse to seeing someone being
accused of sexual assault not fraud or
other other crimes that they are
automatically assumed to be guilty for
every person that said Kevin Spacey was
guilty there should have been 10 people
saying wait until he's been proven
guilty that's the problem one other
thing yeah one other thing if I may
which is the problem of this is It's the
social media thing is you have rapacious
hordes of people who want to demonstrate
their their ostentatious horror and
apparent virtue by standing as being
opponents of the claim but you do not
find rampatious hordes of people going
around social media trying to show that
people are innocent yeah we only have
that it is it is and it's McCarthy I and
it's horrible and is out of control and
as more and more people go into social
media it just gets worse and worse and I
think something has to give these tech
companies have to be held more
accountable for what they allow to be
published on their platforms they just
wouldn't wouldn't I don't actually know
what stats you took on this as you pay
so can you remind me but when um it's
like Donald Trump was banned from
Twitter yeah what was your view on I
don't think he should have been well I
mean where are we supposed to draw the
line here you know I don't think we
should be banning any president giving
it you know unlimited power but I don't
think you should be banished I actually
don't think let me explain that most of
these peopleship I didn't think I think
but should have that much power my
argument was if you're going to allow
the Ayatollah of Iran and the Taliban of
Vladimir Putin to have Twitter accounts
you can't remove it but who decides
exactly if someone says trumps doesn't
hate it well I personally don't think
Elon Musk a private billionaire who's
you know a weird guy she's given that
much
powerful but you can do it yourself oh
really sorry have you you can do what
you like very quick say what you like
[Laughter]
happy birthday Mick Jagger please stop
having kids Douglas Murray meet Jack is
the same age as Joe Biden I mean is
there not evidence right there that Joe
Biden's problem is not his age it's
everything else
all I can say is that if Mick Jagger
were running for president I'd back him
well Mick Jagger come on he's a
he's asking
that's the problem
I mean no what no happy birthday to him
but happy birthday
can't we all Embrace Mick Jagger 80 the
greatest
incredible no he doesn't he doesn't give
anything credible energy great role
model loves to Mick Jagger the greatest
front man in the history of rock music
Happy Birthday Mick keep on rocking keep
giving us satisfaction